>> I AM AL GORE, I USED TO BE
THE NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Harris: YES, THAT WAS GORE'S
CLIMATE CHANGE MOVIE
INCONVENIENT TRUTH IN 2006.
NOW  ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
HAS ONE OF HER OWN, IT HIT OVER
THE WEEKEND AND PLAYED ON 120
SCREENS AND DREW IN $80 PER
THEATER, THAT IS POULTRY, HERE
IS A PEEK.
>> SOME OF US HAVE TO ACTUALLY
LIVE THE FUTURE THAT YOU ALL ARE
SETTING.
>> WE WILL MAKE HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY, SEIZE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
>> WE GOT THE CANDIDATE TO COME
TO US,
>> WE WILL GO OUT IN A BLAZE OF
GLORY OR WIN WHAT WE WANT.
AMERICA HAS FACED THREATS BEFORE
AND COME OUT STRONGER.
>> Harris: SHE'LL HAVE ENOUGH
BIRTHDAYS TO RUN IN 2024, HOW
MANY DEMOCRATS ARE CAMPAIGNING?
>> HOLD ON.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Harris: FOR THE STINKY
TRAILER.
>> Kennedy:
>> Ashley: NO ONE CARES, PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THEY ARE GOING TO BUY CHRISTMAS
PRESENTS FOR THEIR KIDS, THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO BE BEATEN INTO
SUBMISSION BY
HALLELUJAHSTERICS, WE ALL WANT
THE EARTH TO HEAL.
SHE IS NOT A GOOD MESSENGER AND
THAT IS NOT AT THE TOP OF
PEOPLE'S LIST, IF PEOPLE WANT TO
GO TO A MOVIE, THEY DON'T WANT
TO FEEL GUILTY ABOUT SOMETHING,
THEY WANT ESCAPISM, ESCAPE FROM
HER.
>> Harris: WE SHOULD END THE
SHOW RIGHT NOW, BEEN GREAT TO
HAVE YOU.
CHARLES.
>> Charles: FOLLOW THAT UP, I
LOVE THE PART ABOUT NOBODY CARES
GIGANTIC MOVEMENT, THIS ESG
MOVEMENT IS SO POWERFUL
PARTICULARLY IN EUROPE,
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS WELDED TO
THIS THING AND WILL MAKE OR
BREAK INDUSTRIES, ONE REASON OIL
PRICES ARE UP, YOU CAN'T RAISE
MONEY FOR OIL, TALK ABOUT
DRILLING, NOBODY CARES AND FOUND
A WAY TO MAKE THIS MOVEMENT SO
POWERFUL AND NOTION IS MANKIND
IS BAD.
GET RID OF PEOPLE ISSUE THE
PLANET WILL FLOURISH AND THAT IS
THE END.
>> Harris: UNLESS THEY LIVE
SOUTH OF THE BORDER.
JUST STATING THE FACTS.
THERE IS A LOT OF POPULATION
COMING.
>> Charles: I KNOW, THE CRUX
GOES BACK TO THE 1800S, HOW MANY
TIMES HAVE PEOPLE TOLD US WE
WILL ENJOY THE PLANET AND ALL BE
DEAD.
>> Harris: MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE THE LAST NAME STEVEN
SPIELBERG ORCAMERON.
>> Charles: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN AOC IN THAT LEAGUE JUST YET,
THEAG
THE MESSAGE DOESN'T CHANGE.
WHEN WAS GORE'S TIMESTAMP?
WEREN'T WE SUPPOSED TO BE GONE
BY 2010 OR WHATEVER?
>> SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> I LOST TRACK.
>> Jackie: I'M WILLING TO DO MY
PART TO HELP WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE, THE PROBLEM I HAVE, HOW
MUCH WE'RE SPENDING RIGHT NOW,
SETTING MONEY ONIR FOO, NOT
HAVING AN IMPACT WHEN YOU THINK
OF THE OTHER POLLUTERS NOT
PLAYING BALL WITH US, UNTIL WE
COOPERATE WITH PEOPLE AND GET
TECHNOLOGY RIGHT AND MAKE SURE
BATTERIES ARE NOT DESTRUCTIVE
AND DON'T EXPLODE, WE HAVE A
PLACE TO PROPERLY PUT THEM WHEN
FINISHED WITH THEM OR LIFE SPAN
IS LONG ENOUGH TOUN ARE THE
OOBLT AND CAN TAKE THAT AND DO
IT ACROSS THE WORLD, THAT IS
WHEN WE DO IT, TRYING TO DO IT
HERE AND TELLING THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER INFLATION REDUCTION
ACTS, WHICH HAD REVISIONS IN IT,
SPEND YOUR MONEY NOW, IT IS
RIDICULOUS, PEOPLE HAVE TROUBLE
PUTTING GIFTS UNDER TREE AND GAS
IN THE CAR RIGHT NOW.
>> Charles: WE HAVE TO STRIP
MINE THE ENTIRE PLANET, BEST
INVESTMENT IS COPPER, STRIP MINE
THE WORLD.
PUT TOGETHER BATTERIES WE CAN'T
DISPOSE OF.
>> Harris: IN SWITZERLAND THEY
ANNOUNCED, YOU CANNOT THIS
WINTER PLUG IN YOUR ELECTRIC
CARS.
WE COULD GET THERE, TOO, OUR
GRIDS OR 80% EFFICIENT BECAUSE
OF FOSSIL FUEL AND COAL.
WE ARE NOT THERE EITHER, IF WE
NEED ENERGY SOURCES FOR OTHER
THINGS LIKE HEATING AND DRIVING
WE'RE DEPLETING OUR GRID AND
WILL GET TO A POINT LIKE THEY
DID IN CALIFORNIA, CAN'T PLUG IN
YOUR ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
>> AND THE ELECTRIC GRID CANNOT
BE OVERSTATED, THIS WEEKEND, I
WAS TALKING TO A POWER PLANT
MANAGER AND SHE WAS SO
ENLIGHTENING AND CONFIRMING THAT
FRAGILITY AND THE FACT THERE WAS
NO TRANSITION PROVIDED BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION, YOU GUYS,
THOUGH, THIS MOVIE MADE $9000 ON
OPENING DAY WEEKEND, $9000 UNDER
BIDEN AMERICA, THAT MEANS $500,
WHAT A JOKE.
LAST TIME I CHECKED, PEOPLE
INNEN QUEENS VOTED HER IN TO
ENACT POLICY, PRESERVE JOBS,
GROW JOBS, ENSURE TAX DOLLARS
ARE SPENT KEEPING THEM SAFE AND
SECURE NOT TO NARRATE SOME HYPER
HYSTERIC CLIMATE CHANGE
DOCUMENTARY, GET OUT OF HERE
SOCIAL MEDIA INFLUENCERS AND GET
A SEAT AVAILABLE FOR AN ACTUAL
CONGRESS PERSON.
>> Har